and then the bankers I'm
really stationed here to follow all
the evolution of the challenges the group
I believe that
there were about ten large groups
that were made during these months
we try to follow things in an
objective way to give
Greek public opinion
there the reality the reality is that we
are in a very difficult position
and that we have to find a way out of the
Greek problem and that the Greek problems
are not a national problem but
it is a problem  from all over europe
it is very expensive to make a
connection via a satellite network all
the time and all day long
for the programs of
and rémy politique or for other
programs the developments the
skype connection public television must give
the real  makes the information completely
real and in an objective way to
pass the word
on the side even the Greek side of
the Hellenic government succeeded on the side
on the part of the institutions on the part
of the c  advice from the
european community follows four
weeks without sleep i get up at 5
am because the
radio programs in greece start at 6
am and i sleep at two o'clock at night
so i hope that  it's over and it
ends well